[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous retrouvons ce soir
l'équipe de mons en baroeul en septième
semaine n'est ce pas monsieur le maire
monsieur pelletier de mons en baroeul
vous êtes ce soir en septième semaine je
crois que c'est un très bon résultat
je suis très heureux de notre équipe
soit arrivé à cet exploit de gagner
cette semaine en suivant j'espère
qu'aujourd'hui ça sera encore la
victoire finale puisque vous m'avez
appris la semaine dernière que c'était
la dernière session de ce jeu et combien
je le regrette que notre équipe ne
puisse encore continuer à moins que
l'équipe de luc sur mer que je salue
viennent troubler cette harmonie de
victoire eh bien oui c'est en effet
l'équipe de luc sur mer qui ce soir va
tenter de faire chuter mons en baroeul
luc sur mer avec son maire monsieur chat
briatte bonsoir monsieur le maire soir
manuel fraga
alors vous êtes venu vous aussi
encourager votre équipe
et oui je suis venu encourager notre
équipe pour nous le plus important
c'était de participer à ce jeu et nous
tombons heureusement pour la dernière
émission devant l'équipe de mons en
baroeul une équipe qui est une équipe
extrêmement valeureuse et de ce fait si
hélas nous arrivons à résultat le
négatif et bien nous non
un peu de gloire quand même d'avoir
essayé de résister à une équipe pareille
mais oui bien sûr et bien moi je ne
dirai qu'un seul mot que le meilleur
gagne n'est ce pas max favalelli
certainement peut-être pourriez-vous
nous présenter les deux équipes mais
bien sûr l'équipe de mons que vous
connaissez toujours inchangé monsieur
grabovski chef d'equipe monsieur honnart
et mademoiselle carré et l'équipe de luc
sur mer
madame ce cube ski chef d'equipe
monsieur fargier et mademoiselle bruno
max favalelli comment se porte
mademoiselle iris très bien nous irons
lui porter des fleurs ensemble puisque
nous allons hélas mourir à la fin de
cette émission est toujours gaillard eh
bien je vais demander à madame de me
dire pile ou face à face
c'est pile c'est donc l'équipe de mons
qui va commencer
monsieur voyelles eux voyaient y
consomme t console elle lieu et consoles
b les consomment
m
trente secondes
dix secondes
top
combien de lettres
5 et 5 par le même mot litres et élite
chaque équipe marque 5 points et bien
mesdames et messieurs quel dommage pour
une fois nous avions deux mots de cette
lettre je vous pardonne de ne pas hormis
d'élite dont on parle beaucoup dans les
femmes savantes mais je ne vous pardonne
pas de ne pouvoir me liberté à mons 5
luc cinq ans vous madame vous voyez eux
consomment s et voyelles et consonnes
riz et consomme t
prendre ces banques
dix secondes
top
c'est 6 et 6 aussi la leur étude et
bévues et tu vaux plurielle et bévues
chaque équipe marque 6 points et bien h
et maintenant a dit rice le ciel on
dirait une cocotte de la bbpa qui a pas
mieux avec des mots de s'il intéresse
aussi avait en outre débuté au pluriel
buvez qui est un breuvage pour les
bestiaux ou vêtus et c'est enfin il y
avait que des solutions de silène
montez lutte 11 monsieur voyelles à b
consomment des voyelles y voyons et
consonnes b est pourquoi d
trente secondes
on
dix secondes
top
combien 4,5 pour l'équipe de r madame
anne on avait donné un mot c'est trop
tard l'équipe de moussa fait le mauvais
oeil s'est donc mons qui marquent quatre
coins les bravos je regrette qu'elle
n'ait pas évident ce qui m'aurait tout à
fait réhabiliter may avec des mots de
quatre lettres en effet il y avait près
il y avait la baie y'avait l'aide et il
y avait évidemment la paire parfait
madame veil n y voyez et voyelles et
consonnes f
trente secondes
dix secondes
top quand bien que quatre car le vrai
mot max vous serez content byd quatre
points pour chaque équipe n'a
décidemment on entendra au temps du nez
de cyrano et bien il y avait un lot de
six lettres mais sans danic est à ces
savants c'est bifide d isf ide qui est
en deux parties la langue du serpent par
exemple les bifide revient dans la
mienne monstre 19 luc 15 et voiliers
haut
trente secondes
je
dix secondes
top ou bien seuls 5 et 5 aussi ourdi et
froid
cinq points pour chaque équipe oui bien
uniquement des mousses sa lettre foreman
manger dirige également on aurait pu
ajouter faillirent causer et puis le
douro est une monnaie d'argent en
espagne
mons 24 luc 19 madame moyenne aux
consoles c'est qu'on sonne elle voyait a
enfin est ce qu'on sait c'est que
monsieur t
trente secondes
dix secondes
top
vous viendrez être 4 5 4 pour l'udc et 5
pour mons talk au pluriel cinq fois pour
mons
oui attendez je vais rester par pure
acquis de conscience
oui bien sûr mais il y avait un talent
aux yeux
il y avait mieux messieurs il y avait
six lettres mesdames et messieurs il n'y
avait qu'à l'eau voilà me muriel et avec
ostal par exemple christine et moi
pendant les vacances avons fait un
séjour costa ça fait très haute compte
de l'individu plutôt qu'aux côte à côte
d'azur mons 29 luc 19 à vous monsieur
consonnes et comme aime à le consommer
trente secondes
dix secondes
top
5 5 et 5 le même mot à toulouse a
vérifié dit l'équipe de mons c'est
l'événement pour les deux équipes
elles-mêmes ou remarquer à tour
évidemment l'emploi qu'au pluriel mais
dans leur expression dame d'atours on
est à tour au singulier alors je prends
sur moi
vous devriez mclane est d'ailleurs toute
façon les deux équipes ont le même
mesure ce n'est pas bien grave même s'il
ya un acceptons le pour la beauté de la
chose et si elles ont leur tous le même
qui avait des mots de saint cloud qui
comportait aucun danger
c'était ultra par exemple les ultras de
la politique ou ce qu'on donne pour
recevoir c'est à dire waouh air a obtenu
une restitution mondaine mons 34 luc 24
à vous madame royal y voyons des
consonnes et voyelles des eaux
trente secondes
dix secondes
top
combien l'art 6 5 et 6 pour luc voulu
lecanu oui c'est exact il n'y a qu'un
nul le mot de mons louve 5 points pour
mance bien mais enfin il ya un mode side
est que vous auriez pu me jeter c'est le
dévolu mais est vrai aux élus
bravo quand même mons 39 luc 24
monsieur voyelles et consonnes c'est
trop fort
v wii et consoles
r
trente secondes
dix secondes
top 6
si ce qu'ont bien madame annoncé 6 6
sophie coudre etc odeurs et l'odeur cod
ou ère pour l'équipe de lui khodr alors
là une petite minute parce que il faut
tout de même que je m'assure assuré je
crois pas remarqué que coburn ont refusé
pour l'équipe de lui que je veux c'est
donc oui exactement les mêmes lettres
c'est donc l'équipe de mons qui marque 6
points wii et vous aviez su réussir ici
cinq ans de lier trois activités
possibles vous pouviez coude et vous
pouviez coudre ou vous pouvez je ne vous
recommande pas vous pouviez également
pouvait mons 45 luc 24 y voyait une s
console s boullier et les consomment
m
trente secondes
dix secondes
top qu'on y avait trois bus le même but
trois points pour chaque équipe
est-ce que mademoiselle iris faisait
maintenant azéris en est restée muette
de saisissement d'ailleurs mais il y
avait que burnley c'était la seule
solution à trois
mons 48 l'ue27 villemur oui ça y est je
veux dire qu'il n'est pas mieux
le 3e voyage aux voiliers à des profanes
s
ap
la nhtsa secondes
dix secondes
top combien 4 4 et 4 le même mot fou 4
points pour chaque équipe
oui rien que des mots de quatre lettres
en effet il y avait foule hier des
seuils avait sauf sauf à nous et sonnac
est un ensemble de cellules non 52 lits
31 à vous madame au confort des
baigneurs et les voyelles et
trente secondes
[Musique]
dix secondes
top 4 4 et 3 seulement pour l'udc le mot
de monstres maya emma y a oui il s'agit
pas de la pièce de théâtre estime mais
ce jour par jean temps madame qui me
disent est ce que ce n'est pas gagné
dans la religion bouddhique que c'est
l'ensemble des illusions mozilo
dictionnaire qui constitue notre monde
je sais qu'il y en a oh que oui non ce
56 luc 31
monsieur consonnes w1 voyelles au b
trente secondes
et encore 5 minutes de jeu
dix secondes
tapez convient 4 4 et 4 par le même mot
au v pour mons et beuve
pour l'udc et aux verts ouais bo bo vie
à bord
je connaissais un écrivain emmanuel bove
mai or à quoi pensez-vous madame penser
à une définition
bonjour à vous pensez aux vins et oui
mais non le besoin ne se décline pas et
nous n'avons pas bob et je suis obligé
de refuser également d'ailleurs mons en
baroeul parce que l'édition 1970 dans ce
dictionnaire ne comporte plus le parti
s'ils pouvaient en forme d'oeuf disparu
avait supprimé bien par conséquent
qu'une des équipes mais marquez et je
reprends toutes les lettres à vous
madame vous ayez eu console s y consomme
est ce concert r3 yen à vous voyez nos
eaux
37 secondes
dix secondes
top 7
cette pour mons en baroeul m'asseoir et
bien voilà un très beau mot de cette
lettre oui bien sûr je vois de
l'inquiétude sur le visage de mon sens
bien on est 3 du coup abonde n'étaient
pas exagérés pression vous en restez un
peu assis mais bravo travers et
supporteurs applaudissent et
mons-en-baroeul marque 7.63 luc 31
monsieur voyelles et consonnes et
consomme elle bouillait une voyelle a
brillé et et consomme h
trente secondes
dix secondes
tap
que rien lettres 4 3 seulement pour
l'icg by quatre points pour mons oui
très bien c'est un bal qui va pas tarder
et résilié d'ailleurs mon 67 luc tromper
à madame voyelles et consonnes voyez eu
pour elle
trente secondes
eh bien madame messieurs l'émission est
terminée
voyons le score le score définitif mons
en baroeul 67 luc-sur-mer 31
eh bien vous le voyez s'étaient pas
montrés difficile de battre mons en
baroeul et c'est à vous madame que je
vais remettre une boîte de notre jeu
c'est moi qui vous remercie d'être venus
jouer et bien bravo à l'équipe de mons
vous étiez ce soir madame et messieurs
en septième semaine
c'est très très beau peut-être russie et
vous rattraper la sympathique équipe de
camblanes et meynac jusqu'à présent
détenait le record avec neuf victoires
et un match nul
mais cela nous ne serons jamais en tout
cas bravo à vous eh bien chers amis
comme je voulais dit la semaine dernière
c'était ce soir notre dernier
rendez-vous aussi toute l'équipe du
moule plus long armand jammot francis
caillaux max favalelli yvette plailly
marie noëlle bocquillon et moi même nous
vous remercions de votre fidélité à
cette émission et nous vous disons au
revoir
[Musique]
on